- Yo mama so short, you can see her legs
on her driver's license.
Oh that's funny!
(bleeps) you, kids!
(children laugh)
- Yo mama so stupid, she thought seaweed
was something that fish smoke.
- Yo mama so ugly, when
she looked out her window
she got arrested for mooning.
(gasps)
- Yo mama so old, she sat
next to Moses in third grade.
But see, I think Moses was a slave.
So like, I don't think Moses
ever really got educated.
- Yo mama so dumb, she
stared at orange juice
for 30 minutes because it said (laughs)
concentrate.
(laughs)
- Yo mama so ugly, Hello
Kitty said goodbye.
(laughs)
I like that one.
Bye, bitch.
- Yo mama so old, when I told
her to act her age, (laughs)
she died.
(laughs)
- Yo mama so ugly, her
reflection said, I quit.
- These are too clean.
They could be like, I
wouldn't (bleeps) your mama,
something like that.
- I keep reading the same ones.
Yeah that's the thing, I need my glasses.
Yo mama's so blind,
I don't have one for that, let's see.
- Yo mama so stupid, she
got fired from M&M factory
for throwing out the Ws.
There are M&Ms that have Ws?
- Yo mama so ugly, when she
came out of the haunted house,
she had an application.
Damn, ugly to the point where she workin'
at a haunted house for free, minimum wage.
Woo.
- Yo mama so stupid, when Terminator said,
I'll be back, she
actually waited. (laughs)
I would wait for Arnold Schwarzenegger,
to be honest with you.
- Yo mama so stupid,
she thinks a quarterback is a refund.
That's a good one.
Like, give me my quarter back, bruh.
(laughs) Give me my quarter back.
- They need to be more 21st
century jokes, you know?
More gender equality type of your mama.
Yo mama looks like your papa.
(laughs) How 'bout that one?
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.